do not occur in a uniform blank around
the coast of the earth they occur in
veins like gold and silver
okay in some places they only have three
minerals if you're not supplementing
with all 60 you're 57 chart you're going
to get all these diseases okay including
okay including what we're talking about
today now when you're talking about the
cholesterol
issue doctors you know we're looking at
clogged arteries are saying okay the
plug in the Arts is caused by eating
cholesterol stop eating eggs stop eating
fatty Meats more like a vegetarian and
you won't get plaque in your arteries
well that was nonsense because plaque in
the origin is caused by eating fried
foods processed Meats with nitrates and
nitrates
um
and being short and minerals okay
because again nutritional minerals are
not occurring uniform blank around the
custody Earth they occur in veins like
gold and silver
and we did have bottomland some of you
will not remember bottomland uh Every
Spring when the snow and the ice would
melt up in the mountains they'd have
these big floods coming down into the
valleys and they would pick up the
minerals along the way okay in the soil
up in the mountains and bring it down to
the valleys and replace the minerals in
the soil and the bottom land
were had been taken out by the plants in
the previous year by the crops in
previous year
when they came up with hydroelectric
where they put up the dams dammed up the
rivers and streams so there was no more
flooding no more silt to plow back in
the cell every year suddenly now we had
all these diseases nobody ever seen
before
okay is a mess
okay now let's get back to cholesterol
because it's all kind of related
cholesterol makes up
25 of your brain weight
25 percent of your spinal cord weight
makes up 95 percent of testosterone
weight 95 of estrogen progesterone
weight
cholesterol
is an extremely important raw material
for basic tissues and function okay
and when doctors said oh it's the
cholesterol they came out with drugs
like statin drugs to lower the
um cholesterol in your body
and then people said oh yes well stop
eating eggs and animal fat and you'll
lower cholesterol and suddenly now we
have all these diseases that are
cholesterol deficiency diseases
okay
so it's absolutely imperative to eat
three eggs twice a day with soft yolks
kids can have one or two scrambled eggs
in butter okay soft scrambled soft
boiled soft poached not fried okay
and not hard-boiled then
um people say oh they get Alzheimer's
disease you get all this stuff because
of of cholesterol no no no no no no
heart attacks are not caused by
cholesterol brain stuff is not caused by
cholesterol it's caused by cholesterol
deficiency okay and so this is not
difficult and so that's why we have I-26
it says around the label provides 25 of
your daily requirement of cholesterol we
have the only product in the market that
has in the label saying that it gives
you a percentage of the cholesterol you
need every day as a supplement
okay that goes along with your healthy
brain and heart pack
and there are three eggs twice a day
with soft yolks
and it's imperative okay
and when doctors say oh your cholesterol
is too high we've got to get you on
statin drugs say okay Doctor you're
fired and go away and find another
doctor
okay because you'll wind up with
Alzheimer's disease you'll wind up with
Ms multiple sclerosis you wind up with
the game Barn disease which again great
disease is as multiple sclerosis of your
spinal cord and then there's Parkinson's
disease which is multiple sclerosis with
tremors and then there's the new one
which is FTD okay frontal temporal
dementia which is kind of like a little
Regional Alzheimer's disease
okay and then
um the demon colonization
now they only learned a hundred years
ago and before that they could only
learn about demolinization after you
died and they did an autopsy on you
because most people were not going to
let a doctor do
a biopsy of your brain
okay okay
but demolinization is a cholesterol
deficiency and so if you want to have a
great sex life you know in addition to
taking your health abandoned heart pack
you throw in a guy you want to throw in
the zero test girls you want to throw on
the xerofem don't forget your
um
let's see here I also want to throw in
the I-26
and it's one of those things where
um you you want to make sure you're
taking everything you need to make sure
your skull is working properly you don't
have obviously a process of the skull
because doctors are going to really
really blame a lot of those symptoms on
cholesterol and take you off of all
cholesterol and put you on cholesterol
or wrong drugs and you'll spiral
downwards and die very quickly okay so
with that said that's sort of a summary
of what I want to talk about about
cholesterol cholesterol is one of your
best friends if you like sex you want
cholesterol if you like your memory you
want cholesterol if you want to be able
to function and perform at your job and
get promoted all the time you want
cholesterol and so again 75-year track
record here
in the in the book uh the Wallach
Revolution and of course epigenetics
those two books together I think are a
good set okay there you go epigenetics
and it's all in your head
um and don't forget that one and of
course Rebecca and Dr Milan and I
um did that and there's a there's a CD
that goes along with it because in a
year after this book came out we're
getting so much great positive feedback
we did a CD with more information so
when we get when the supply of the book
gets low we're going to add a lot of
this information new information to the
book but we'll keep the CED anyway
because people like to listen to that CD
so
and if you want proof about why we're in
trouble because
when we went to electricity okay after
three thousand years of getting our
minerals from wood ashes and coal ashes
get the book Hell's Kitchen just had a
bad
um area in New York City where
everything bad happens okay Hell's
Kitchen these things
will tell you what's going on here
get a hold of that book
um
let's see here rare Earth's been cures
rare Earth's been cures
do you have a third hand
four or five doc okay rare has been
cures there you go tells you how to
collect hair or a ship it how to read
the hair analyzes everybody should be
getting a hair analyzes once a year you
do not need permission from a doctor to
get a hair analysis and you can only
learn from a blood test about your blood
levels of iron and
and also calcium
there's 60 essential minerals that you
can't tell much about from a blood
sample okay but you can from the hair
analysis also the hair analysis has
another chart in it which gives you how
many toxic minerals you have and how
much of each toxic metal you have you
know we're talking about lead and
mercury and uranium and so on and so
forth and these are things if you want
to add these 25 to 50 Health years your
life you got to do this and then I'm
going to throw in I think I've got what
two minutes here or something like that
like that
something like that okay
let me give give me two more minutes
okay and so I want to talk about Jimmy
Carter he's 98.
um you know I'm not into his politics
but he's 98 years old and and his
doctors wanted to put him into the
hospice because he's 98 years old not
because he had anything wrong with him
but he's 98 years old saying let's put
you in hospital so we can take care of
you something happens he says no thank
you I'll just go home and he did
98 years old and he's lived on grits
which is cornmeal and
um eggs which you're not supposed to
have he's lived on um let's see here
Seafood
and vegetables and fruit
and um he lives on uh which is a corn
and all that kind of stuff
and he only had peanuts like once a week
not every day and he was a peanut guy
and so the odds are he can live to be
120.
now he's the oldest living president
ever
and you know he told the doctors to take
off when they said that you need to come
in and get into hospice well why well
you're 98 years old well age has nothing
to do with the need to go into hospice
if you're you know dying because you
have 18 different diseases and you can't
breathe and stuff you might want to go
into hospice
but if there's nothing wrong with you
and you're paying golf once a week like
he is
okay and going fishing and hunting on a
regular basis why would you want to go
into hospice
well my doctor said okay so I think I've
made my point
eat like Jimmy Carter
take our 90 essential nutrients stay
away from all the bad stuff and add 25
to 50 Health years your life we want you
around
over to you Becca
I'm gonna leave out the peanuts just
because yeah I don't take it at all I
don't take them at all
no nor do I well Dr Wall like that
I hope that makes some clarity for
people in regards to cholesterol because
that's one of the very first things that
people come to me with when they have
gone to the doctor they've gotten some
blood work back and they said well my
cholesterol is high my first question is
well what is hi
because I know people that they've been
at 105. Dr Wallach on their cholesterol
and they're being put on a Statin drug
and 105 is very low as it is yes
and they're still wanting it to be lower
and then we wonder why do we have so
many people
that are struggling with brain functions
well and and that's he's an extreme but
I'm talking about
it's like an epidemic Dr Wallach where
people they've got brain fog they're not
able to function they get tired easily
um they their memory well that's because
misinformation about cholesterol and
insurance pays for the test an insurance
pays for the medication so people say
well what the heck insurance pays for
everything if it makes the doctor happy
lets the insurance pay for and I'll do
it well Bruce Willis paid a price
okay he's only 67 years old and he had
to retire he can't remember his own name
can't remember where he lives I mean
that's a terrible thing for the Die Hard
Detective
he was one of my heroes so we're trying
to connect with his family and because I
believe we can bring Bruce Willis back
okay into being the Die Hard Bruce
Willis that I knew and loved and
respected
well until you are no longer requiring
oxygen
there's a lot you can still do right now
you need cholesterol
yeah you need cholesterol
oh my goodness lots of great information
thank you so much for taking the time
everybody to join us and just be a
sponge with the information that's being
shared so that whenever the time comes
and you're you're talking to somebody
you could just squeeze a little bit of
water out and say you know what I heard
this doctor talking about cholesterol
and I know that there's a recording
somewhere how would you like to listen
to it well you can send them to daily
with
doc.com and there you will find the
recordings of all of our programs that
that we have done Dr Wallach since we
were doing ass doc live
uh each and every Friday for two hours
way back July of 2020 so two and a half
years ago we were doing that
so we have been gathering together and
sharing information
for for a few years now Dr Wallach and
it's just getting better and better and
better
I love it
can't thank you enough
well thank you Dr Wallach because if it
wasn't for your research we wouldn't
have anything to share well right well
your team and myself the whole group we
make a good team don't we
yes we do yes we do and I just want to
do a quick little reminder for
because they do destroy the lining of
the intestines your Villi go away so you
lose that absorptive surface
and
um you have to get off those grains I
just apologize all the farmers because I
I was one I apologize to the farmers
they can still grow wheat around oats
but they have to feed it to animals that
they're only going to feed for three
months and then send them to Market
okay use it as animal feed not for human
feed okay we'd run around oats and then
and no buckwheat because they have
phagopirines f-a-g-o-pyrians which are
worse than gluten buckwheat doesn't have
any gluten in it but it has Bagel
Pyrenees there's your worst gluten okay
and so it's one of those things where
you do have to give up the bad stuff and
you have to consciously proactively use
supplements so this guy is going to give
up the bad stuff no fried foods no
processed Meats no oils no glutens no
wheat nobody knows when I say processed
Meats we're talking about bacon and ham
and hot dogs and bologna and salami and
Pastrami and pepperoni anything with
nitrates in it because that will kill
your thyroid gland that was my first
scientific publication where 500 died in
one night because the the temperature
dropped from in the 50s down to 16 in
one night and 500 sheep just ready to
get sheared and go to market to six
month old they're perfect everybody
healthy nothing bad going on and all 500
of them died in the night when the
temperature dropped down to 16 even
though they had two inches of wool in
their sheep and and so forth because
they've been getting nitrates in their
drinking water from contamination from
fertilizer from the surrounding Farms
I'm a student and I figured all that out
and got it published okay it was my
first scientific publication and
um Marlon Perkins from the old Mutual
Omaha Kingdom show
okay and very common are the head of the
Department of biology at the University
of Missouri
um
um or Washington University excuse me
Washington University and University
City okay St Louis actually
um got a 25 million dollar Grant with
that uh article that I wrote on those
sheep
and um that started everything and of
course my thesis from that is in the
Smithsonian Institute as a national
Treasurer base they um let's see here
that's the epigenetics book okay the
original book
um
sells for twenty five thousand dollars
each no very few people can afford that
okay you can get this one the
epigenetics for 25 bucks each okay
um it's one of those things where the
information
will add 25 to 50 Health years your life
and so this
um group epigenetics has replaced the
science of genetics genetics was a false
Theory again like like the cholesterol
genetics was a false Theory when doctors
didn't know something and say oh it's
genetic because your body attacked
himself oh you saw them you and your
body is attacking himself because they
didn't ever want to say they didn't no
they were all knowing they were medical
doctors
and so
um the epigenetics changed all that and
so I'm very very proud to be one of the
founding fathers of that science
and
it was based on the studies that we did
at Washington University in St Louis
County okay it was just a big big big 10
years 20 000 autopsies
and what should I say it just changed
all of Medical Science I'm very proud of
that
okay
so I hope that answers the question
I I think so so well I mean he's
experiencing gluten I mean he's
experiencing bloating and digestive
issues oh yeah so he needs to get off
all the gluten needs to get off all the
fried foods and you know all the bad
stuff sugar and carbonated drinks and
oils and all that kind of stuff get rid
of all the bad foods we have the book Dr
wallach's cooking without the bad foods
300 pages of safe recipes and safe
cooking methods Dr always cooking
without the bad foods he needs to get
that book he needs to get the book
epigenetics
these gift book the book The Wall
Revolution okay and then
um I want him at uh you say 200 plus
pounds I want him to actually uh get uh
our
um Heather brainer heart pack he can
take two of those per month the
photosync twice a day he needs to get
two bottles a month of our MSM so we
take three at breakfast lunch at dinner
time they're going to support and
promote major pair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between the vertebrae bone makes
bone itself and then
um and because when you have
osteoporosis of the skull thank you
thank you thank you how she approaches
this goal squeezing the tense cranial
nerve the vagus nerve you get what's
called gastroparesis you have belching
bloping burping I mean tremendous uh
stomach pain it'll bring you to your
knees and doctors think you have an
ulcer but it's just how she approaches
the skull squeezing that tense cranial
nerve the vagus nerve and then
let's see here
um he can also take our ultimate enzymes
take two of those say five or ten
minutes for each meal a couple ounces of
water and that should help with that
also and then give us a call every
couple of weeks and let us know how it's
going because these things that he has
will turn around to normal within weeks
within two to six weeks so I'll be
normal if he's on medication for high
blood pressure don't cold turkey off of
that but as your blood pressure drops
and your solar reduced medication if
he's got diabetes and don't cold turkey
off that medication but as the blood
sugar slowly comes to normal he can
slowly reduce that but this is all
something we deal with thousands of
times a day all over the world we're
dealing in 80 countries and this is a
very common scenario
yes it is Dr Wallach I experienced it
myself years ago there you go thankfully
I have that behind me
let's go to Rosemary who we have again
with us today Rosemary go ahead and
unmute yourself you're on live with us
try again there it is okay well first
off I want to thank you for yesterday's
program it was very very informative
thank you and I really enjoyed it
she talked about a client or patient of
hers who had a prolapsed bladder
yes about 30 years ago I was diagnosed
with prolapse uterus are they similar
what's the yeah well the same same cause
you're missing things that make the
tendons and ligaments do their job hold
everything's in place
and
um when you have a prolapse you have a
hernia this is because you're missing
things that are required to keep your
tendons and ligaments
and connective tissue strong and doing
their jobs
okay
so I kind of like
um
anytime you know you have a yo-yo and
you leave it Go and it'll go down to the
bottom of the string
okay that's that's the same as a
prolapse
yo-yo you're supposed to balance it back
up so it'll line back up okay and get it
again okay but you can't do that with
your uterus you can't do that with your
bladder what you have to do is
um actually
get pads and everything to hold
everything in place what you want to do
is when you
sleep at night put a four by four under
the feet of the bed so gravity is
pulling the uterus and the bladder back
into your belly into your pelvis area
okay but you wear that hernia device
okay and it'll hold things into place
and that way you won't actually get
things dirty and injured and where you
have to have surgery and get infections
and all kind of stuff it's the secondary
things that gets you when you have
hernias okay those kind of things so you
got to pay attention usually people who
have those kind of things have white
gray or silver hair because the same
nutrients that are missing that cause
hernias and prolapses
also cause a loss of hair color
well this is my natural
I am blonde
um I have noticed I am blonde and this
is my natural color it looks just like
it did 30 years ago good and 40 years
ago
um
I did notice when I got on the 90 that
it stopped it from getting worse
and then I also got on uh immortalium
and that actually helped it quite a bit
okay how old are you now I'm 77. okay
um
I run around with pictures in my purse
because people think I'm I'm gray-headed
and I show them what I look like 50
years ago and I saw the same color
so
but um
it's not painful it's not deadly and so
I've just been living with it
doctors want to do a hysterectomy and I
don't
know again you can get pads it was kind
of a a belt and braces and everything
that'll hold things in place during the
day when you're vertical but at night
you want to put that four by four under
the feet of your bed so gravity helps
you pull everything back into where it
belongs I'll do that
foreign is there anything else I can do
nutritionally that would help yeah yeah
of course you need things that are going
to be good for your tendons and
ligaments and connective tissue okay and
you weigh how much again
125. okay so I'd have you take because
you do have a a problem the doctors want
to do surgery on
I would have you take two healthy pain
and heart patch a month I weigh 142 and
I do two Health abandoned heart faction
month photos showing twice a day I also
want you to have two bottles a month of
our MSM so you can take three breakfasts
three unless you dinner time and they're
going to support and promote maintenance
repair of cartilage ligaments tendons
connected
changes between bone makes air all that
kind of stuff including all the tendons
and ligaments that hold the uterus and
bladder into place okay and they'll make
those ligaments and tendons their normal
size and length and strength and so
forth
and then
um
and see here I also want you to take our
collagen peptides take a
um two canisters of animals you can take
a scoop without your morning drinks with
your evening drink
okay
and uh let's go there
okay I'm on most of that already so
again I'm assuming you're done cycling
since you're in your 70s you don't cycle
anymore yeah that's true okay all right
now if you want to you can also um don't
forget the three eggs twice a day but
you can do that okay but you can also
throw in the Zara femme
um it'll help your glands make some
estrogen and your estrogen is going to
help you also keep your uterus in the
right place
okay okay
because it's called Zera femme
and your body weight you go ahead and
take three a day take one with each meal
you can take all three at one meal
whatever you want to do
okay
okay thank you
all right thank you Rosemary keep going
keep going
love to hear that you're feeling
positive results already that is awesome
now Dr Wallach in the comments there's a
question that has to do because you had
mentioned nitrates and they're wanting
to know how about the uncured meats that
do not have added nitrates are they okay
yeah you can have like salted Meats
um where you have you know things
hanging on the line out there and
they've they've cut meat into strips and
put salt on it and
um so forth and it's just
jerky yeah jerky kind of stuff
yeah okay that's fine salt is fine salt
is a requirement of course we have we
like the
the
um the salts okay that has the seasoning
in it it's got the 28 minerals in it
this is from Australia New Zealand okay
also once in a while we'll get the
um salt from the Himalayan Mountains the
himalayans of salt okay the salt is a
required nutrient any doctor would say
to you don't take salt because it causes
blood pressure that's absolutely wrong
sodium is required for the functioning
of every cell in your body chloride is
required in every cell in your body
particularly in your stomach cells that
make hydrochloric acid you cannot absorb
minerals you cannot digest food without
hydrochloric acid the good lord gave us
okay the ability to make stomach acid so
we can digest food
okay so staying away from Salt you're
committing a slow painful miserable
suicide
most definitely
and then Margaret had mentioned in the
comments here she said that her son was
sensitive to wheat 36 years ago and they
found that it was even in common
licorices that are red that are were so
tasty I mean they hide
gluten and wheat products Rye barley
oats in so many different things that
sometimes it's just occurs in those
natural flavorings
so you want to make sure that you're
really reading labels
yeah well doctors are giving out
misinformation that the the salt is bad
for you and gluten is good for you okay
the whole grains are good for you wheat
bread around oats The Breakfast of
Champions Wheaties Cheerios
okay
um
um and then of course there was the um
spaghetti and bread and pancakes and
waffles I mean that's why I was so sick
when I was nine years old I was eating
waffles and spaghetti and Wheaties and
oatmeal every day
and it's amazing I didn't die okay
me too I I was eating it all the time
and then so a topic for the future Dr
Wallach we will be studying up on the
different natural alternative sweeteners
like Xylitol and erythritol and monk
fruit so we've got some questions in
regards to sweeteners so we're
definitely going to be covering that
also in a future episode of daily with
dog yeah we'll put together the
information thanks
yeah absolutely and we love questions we
love comments so we want to make sure
that we are providing information that
is
something you're looking for
all right you have questions go to daily
withdoc.com
yes I got it right and use that contact
us and send us a message of the things
that you are interested in knowing about
learning about if you have specific
health concerns and you are not already
working with a health coach you can feel
free to use that contact us we will make
sure that we get information to you or
bring it on the air as a question
so that Dr Wallach himself can use your
question to teach others around the
world for many many years Dr Wallach I
love how we can do one recording and it
can be shared a million times and
watched a million more
well this is a blessing to have this to
have this talent that you and your team
has to put together these tools that we
can they'll be around for a thousand
years after we're gone and I'm just very
excited about that and and so
we do have other projects that are
coming it's going to blow people's minds
okay the the projects we have coming out
here pretty quickly they're they're near
done and I'm I'm so excited about this
and the whole idea is to build this
inventory this this Library if you will
and of course my thesis that I did that
sells for twenty five thousand dollars
each that big 25 million dollar project
at Washington University in St Louis
um that's in the Smithsonian Institute
as a National Treasure
does your doctor have a a thesis in the
Smithsonian Institute as a National
Treasure no no I'm not trying to brag
I'm just saying
somebody saw my my research was of some
value
in the Smithsonian Institute as a as a
National Treasure and I'm in the process
of finding out how many people have a
thesis in the Smithsonian instance who's
National Treasure I'm particularly
looking for how many medical people you
know how many doctors how many nurses uh
how many pharmacists uh and you might
help me with that because you're very
good at that sort of stuff Rebecca let's
find out how many people
do use a computer
um okay and and it's one of those things
where how many people have their thesis
in the Smithsonian Institute as a
National Treasure I guarantee is it's
not a lot okay and so I'm very very
proud of that but it just tells you that
all the things we're talking about are
important you don't get put into the
Smithsonian Institute of the National
Treasure if what you're saying is
frivolous
true
they they do do a little bit of um
Dr Wallach yeah
so
we have another question Dr Wallach and
I think Marilyn has her hand up to ask
it for us Marilyn
yes
um they're in the chat uh on Irene asked
a question she's a female 70 years old
140 pounds and she wants to know why she
has to run to the bathroom every half an
hour she drinks a lot of water to be
hydrated
okay that's very easy
um do you know if she has any ring in
the ears or any balance problems
um she doesn't mention anything else I
don't know if she you have to ask her
these questions
Irene to come on with us
Irene
can you go ahead and unmute yourself
yes I'm here
okay Irene uh thank you for coming on do
you have any ring in your ears any
tinnitus or ringing or roaring or
buzzing in your ears a buzzing like a
seashell okay like like listening to the
seashell okay and then
um do you ever let's see here
um do you also
um you and you wake up at night to
urinate three four five eight ten times
uh at least three times
at least three times yeah okay then do
you have any balance problems any
vertigo any dizziness do you need a
walker or a cane or no anything like
that no okay do you have any trouble
swallowing do you have have your voice
changed anything like that
no okay do you have any irregular
heartbeat or slow heart rate or a past
heart rate
no okay good we have osteoporosis of the
skull
okay the osteoporosis of the skull is
squeezing your spinal cord that's why
you're having these issues with um
polyuria okay because your your skull is
squeezing your spinal cord the spinal
cord is telling your urinary bladder to
urinate I know you don't have a prostate
problem because you're a girl
girls don't have prostate glands now if
you're a boy the first thing that the
medical doctors want to do all we got to
do a biopsy to see if we have prostate
cancer and blah blah blah
but they gotta bite their fingers
when this happens to a lady because you
don't have a prostate gland
okay but the skull is squeezing the
spinal cord because the skull is made in
the brain comes out of the back of the
skull and this is where you need to get
a hold you'll understand this you get a
hold of the book and the CD that there
you go that Rebecca and Dr Milan and I
have done okay it's all in your head and
it goes into 37 different diseases 17 of
which occur from the skull down the
spinal cord okay now when you get
osteoporosis of your knees you get a
double knee replacement when you get
obviously approaches of your hips you
got a double hip replacement but as he
approaches the skull can they give you a
double head replacement of course not
so doctors don't want to talk about
osteoporosis of the skull even if they
know about it but I don't think they
teach that in school to medical school
I'm the guy that discovered this and
this book is one of our best sellers
here it just sells like crazy because
people say well that's me that's me
that's me and the doctor just says I'm
getting old I got to get used to it no
it's because you have osteoporosis of
the skull squeezing those nerves and
squeezing the spinal cord and it all
goes away very quickly when you take the
healthy brain and heart pack you take
the MSM you take the collagen peptides
you take the vitamin D3 don't forget the
synaptive take three of those twice a
day so your brain cells can talk to each
other don't forget your high uh 26 so
your brain cells can talk to each other
okay and with memory and all that kind
of stuff and you know what they need to
do in proper form and so the I-26 I take
three of those a day on breakfast lunch
when dinner sometimes I'll just take all
three at lunchtime along with some
cheese sticks
it tastes good you know they're not
which they don't taste like candy but
they're Pleasant okay you're about the
diameter of a quarter or chewables uh
they're only a millimeter thick but
they're the flat Diamond like a disc
okay like a quarter
and they're chewable and and they're
Pleasant tasty I'll just say they're
Pleasant tasting okay I don't get the
big kick out of the taste but they're
they're Pleasant they don't taste bad
they're not bitter they're not yucky
okay and so
um this is something that you will be
able to very quickly resolve your
problems
all right thank you so much Irene for
coming on and letting doc ask you a few
more questions because it's those
symptoms
you'll notice that Dr Wallick is asking
symptoms about different parts of the
body
and when you think about it it just
totally makes sense because you've got
the vagus nerve that comes here out of
the brain goes down the spinal cord
you've got all the little branches that
are going to every single part of the
brain I mean the body so if something's
happening up here in the brain
how can it not affect things down lower
you'd call it Downstream Dr Wallach yes
yes Downstream stuff
so it totally makes sense this is
something that I was dealing with
and as I was going through all these
different conditions that are listed
here on the book I'm like
um no no yes no you know all the
different things that I could say yes to
and then as time progressed we found
more and more things that had these
symptoms
Dr Wallach did and I'm like
okay we've got the books we can't just
put it back in the book let's do a CD
and added the CD to the book that has
more so with the next edition of it's
all in your head there will be
additional that are added on there and
that just means we have to do another CD
Dr Wallach I know somebody that knows
how to do that and and I think she works
pretty cheap so there we go it's all
about getting the information into the
hands of people that it can help folks
and that's what this program is all
about
Dr Wallach I know that our time with you
is here running short we just thank you
so much again for another 50 minutes of
information that we can utilize
and not just survive but actually Thrive
so thank you Dr Wallach I appreciate you
so much well we're family thank you and
your team and thank you all of our
followers and listeners all of our
youngevity people because the world
needs you the world needs you
um this information must get out there
and that's why we're doing as many books
and CDs and videos and all the things we
can do and of course this program
um let's see here daily with Doc five
days a week holy moly this is very good
stuff thank you so much
and we're live with video and we are
being broad uh live streamed broadcasted
on many different platforms so folks
make sure that you're following us on
YouTube Dr Rolex I'm going to go ahead
and let you go okay thank you so you can
get to your next program
but make sure that you're following us
on YouTube and Rumble and Oops I did the
wrong one
hold on hold on I'm getting ready yeah
he's making fun of me now folks there we
go thank you so much and if I could get
my co-hosts who are helping me out on
that one to come on stream with me I
just want to give them a great big shout
out and thank you because without them I
would not be able to do this there are
so many different moving Parts here
we've got our
our executive of production and make
sure that all the streams are working we
have Marilyn who is part of a production
team here who makes sure that people are
getting information in the chat
and who's not with us we have John D he
is our technical advisor who is just the
master when it comes to websites and all
things production so some power
Productions if you're ever looking for a
production company to help you with your
digital marketing
is my number one recommendation
so on behalf of the daily with Doc show
my name is Rebecca dukes and we invite
you to get back with the person that
shared this program with you if there is
nobody to thank go ahead and go to daily
with doc.com and there we have all of
our replays we have the 10 Good Foods
bad foods list because I know Dr while
it goes through it really fast sometimes
we need something to print out so we can
put it on the refrigerator or you can
even download and save it so that it's
on your phone anytime you go to the
store you have that available and if you
have questions or you'd like to get
started working with a certified
holistic health coach use that contact
us and you will get information and that
will connect you with somebody that can
best fit you where you're at because we
don't just pile things on to pile things
on folks you as an individual are an
individual with individual needs and we
make sure that you're getting what you
need
to get the best optimal results so until
tomorrow
bye for now
foreign
[Music]
ready
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]